why
so as we pick up with original sin issue
number two it's very important that you
guys pay close attention to what's going
on because what we're going to see here
is that these stories are going to take
off they're going to move extremely fast
and so there's not going to be a whole
lot of explanation in terms of who
individuals are and so on just because
for the most part there won't be a whole
lot of time for it we're going to get
quite a bit quite a bit of information
at a very in a very short amount of time
as we progress through these videos so
what we see going on here is we're with
Emma Frost
Scott Lang and Black Panther as they are
near the centre of the planet and what
we see is that they've encountered the
Malloys now the Malloys are the de-facto
henchman of Mole Man more or less and
for the most part they're not really
relevant to this story although I would
like you to keep them in the back of
your head because what we're going to
see is that when we get to our
discussion of old man Logan the Malloys
are going to play a role and so if
you're unfamiliar with them you're going
to be a little confused as to what the
relevance is regarding their characters
in that storyline but what we see is
that Emma Frost and Black Panther are
looking at the Malloys and they're
trying to figure out what's going on in
this environment what we see is that
they've encountered a giant skeleton of
sorts and they more or less figure out
that whoever it was that had been here
whoever it was it had been depositing
bodies here is a person who didn't want
anybody to find it who thought this was
a very well hidden dumping ground in
addition we see Scott Lang is looking
for various sources of radiation Scott
Lang is looking for some kind of
indication maybe gamma or radiation or
something that can help them layout or
find this trail that will lead to who it
was that was dumping bodies in here what
we also see is that Emma Frost is
telepathically speaking with the Malloys
telling them alloys that she's not there
to hurt that none of them are there to
hurt them that they're simply just a
conducting an investigation and they'll
be out of their hair pretty soon but
what we see is that the malloy dimply
state or as far as I'm African tell that
the Boyd's don't really know what's
going on that every few months somebody
comes down there
and some bodies are deposited but they
don't really know where the bodies are
coming from and then at this point we
see a depiction of the fact that there
are a multitude of bodies here and they
all seem to be of alien origin or some
kind of extra dimensional origin all
these bodies belong to monsters some of
which are relatively recent and some of
which are skeletons and making they've
been there for quite some time
from here we switch to a new york city
and we follow the story of Nick Fury
Captain America and others and what we
see going on here is that Nick I'm sorry
that I Captain America Black Widow
spider-man and Wolverine are pursuing
somebody in particular they're pursuing
something although at this point we
don't really know what it is but what we
see is that this is one of the mindless
ones and again these are extra
dimensional beings that for the most
part don't really are not supposed to
really have their own will they simply
just do as they're told more or less and
what we see is that while Captain
America and in spider-man Wolverine and
Black Widow were chasing the mindless
one they're giving Nick Fury information
Nick Fury flying around the side of the
building and they're informing him of
where it's at what we see is that the
mindless one jumps out of the building
and lands in the car in Nick Fury's
hover car and we see that again this
mindless one is displaying telepathy
here dis- ones displaying the fact that
it does have a mind we see that it
pleads with Nick Fury to let it go that
he has to keep running and then he has
to keep running to outrun his own mind
indicating that this was just a sudden
burst of intelligence this was a sudden
introduction of entitle intelligence to
the mindless ones and they don't know
how to deal with this influx of
knowledge and in telepathy indicating
that maybe the thoughts of other
individuals are pushing their way into
their mind because again they don't know
how to control their new newfound
telepathic abilities from here we see
that Nick Fury engages the defenses of
his car to try to subdue the mindless
one but it's not working and this is
very important here the minus one says
that being on the moon was the first
time that he ever knew what sin was and
he asks whether or not a person deserves
to die for their original sin Nick Fury
thinks this is an admission of guilt he
thinks that the mindless one is
admitting that he had killed the watcher
and the mindless one simply replies by
saying that he still can't look
can't bear to look at the watchers I at
this point we see Nick Fury jettison
from the car he initiates the ejection
mode and with his jetpack on is able to
escape and effectively crashes the car
at this point
so we see the minus one pleading bet he
wants to be mindless again that he wants
to he doesn't want to have any sort of
intelligence that he demands to be made
ignorant again but we see that of course
this is not something Nick Fury can
grant and Nick Fury simply just shoots
the car and blows the car up from here
we transition to Doctor Strange and the
Punisher and we see that this system we
just listed as elsewhere it's simply
described to us as somewhere far beyond
the realms of man but what dr. strange
tells us is that this is a realm of
man-eating shadows and again if you
recall our discussion on Doctor Strange
what we had talked about is that dr.
strange during his solo storylines or
even during his story lines of strange
tales would constantly visit various
dimensions some of which were extremely
strange some of which were very
interesting and relatively familiar but
this is an instance of visiting a
dimension whereby the things are very
weird and very odd we see the Punisher
saying that are asking the question if
they thought they were supposed to be
hunting a murderer and Doctor Strange
says yes dr. strange says that's what
we're here for and the Punisher deduces
that they're simply supposed to be bait
in addition we see Doctor Strange say
he's conjured birds
he's conjured these sort of energy based
birds and that they will find a murderer
murder victim regardless of where it is
from here we transition to them
teleporting to the location of the
discovered murder victim and the murder
victim appears to be some kind of a
ancient king of the world as I'm sorry
king of the ancient world rather as
Doctor Strange tells us and that this
creature is quite massive it's pretty
huge in size in addition we see that the
Punisher immediately gets to work on
trying to figure out what in the world
was going on here what in the world it
was that maybe killed this some this
creature caused its death and again at
this point The Punisher is not really
sure why he's along here he's really not
sure why he's been brought here if
they're going to be travelling to other
dimensions where by Doctor Strange is
really the only one who
has any power in these locations but
what we see is that the Punisher deduces
why it is it he's here that he's here to
more or less figure out what killed
these beings while dr. strange keeps
them protected to a degree and we see
that the Punisher is able to locate a
pretty massive gamma-irradiated bullet
now from here we transition back to
earth and we're back with the mindless
once and again the mindless ones are are
quoting different things their their
minds are catching up to the fact that
there's a lot of intelligence to be
gained and we don't really know again
how it is this happened we don't really
know how it is that the mindless ones
were able to gain their abilities shy of
looking into the eye of the watcher in
addition we see that the two unnamed
individuals that we had yet to see are
again in possession of one of the
Watchers eyes and they're talking about
how the the mindless ones are evolving
how they are expanding in terms of their
overall abilities with its so are these
two individuals so they are gaining more
power simply just by being in possession
or maybe looking into the eye of the
watcher from here we see these
individuals continuing to talk these
individuals are saying things like you
know the idea of I'm sorry facing the
Avengers the idea of the fact that the
Avengers will eventually come for them
and we see this individual simply saying
that the Avengers will not be able to
handle this when they arrive that when
the Avengers show up to confront this
individual that the Avengers are going
to be faced with the power of the
Watchers I from here we see this
individual yelling out calling to
various individuals but what we see is
that this this group of individuals are
in fact the Avengers proper that for the
most part all the Avengers including
Nick Fury's team the team of Black
Panther Scott Lang and Emma Frost and
dr. Strange's team are converging on the
on this this tower where these
individuals are housing the mindless
ones in addition to the Watchers eyes
and what we see is that the mindless
ones and exterminate ryx who is the
daughter of dr. Midas begin to attack
the Avengers now exterminators is a
character that we haven't really talked
about yet and in truth she's not really
relevant she's a one of these instances
of a character who's being elevated but
that is it really a character who
matters that much what we see going on
here is that the mindless ones and
exterminate ryx get into a very
drawn-out brawl with the Avengers that
we see that Richard I'm sorry that Sam
Alexander of Nova Corps along with
various other individuals are fighting
the mindless ones and exterminate ryx
but what we also see here is that the
possessor of the Watchers eye is leading
someone who appears to be the thing down
a set of stairs but what we see is that
this is in fact dr. Midas now for those
of you guys who were unfamiliar with
doctor - dr. Midas is an individual who
has the power to turn anything to gold
once he touches it but he's also a
genius-level person now why it is that
dr. - as part of this story it's
something that I have yet to figure out
I'm not really sure why he's here but
what we see is that this individual and
dr. Midas are talking about the Watchers
eye they're talking about how the
watcher has seen everything in human
history and this individual who's in
possession of the eye believes that
everything that the watcher has seen is
still within his eye and he's simply
trying to find a way to to take it out
what we also see here is dr. Midas asks
this individual how do we get the
secrets out of there how do we get the
secrets that the watcher had and this
individual says that he's been trying to
figure that out but he doesn't know the
answer to that in addition we see that
once this individual and dr. Midas get
down to the ground level we see that the
mindless ones have for the most part
been totally defeated by a combination
of the thing of the fantastic for the
full new Avenger Sam Alexander and storm
of the x-men including daredevil and
various other superheroes and what we
see is that this individual begins to
reveal himself this individual says that
the Watchers eye is a bomb and that all
bombs go boom from here we're going to
bring him into this story and we'll pick
up with issue number three where we
learn what happens when everyone is
exposed to the to the eye of The Watcher
and what happens when everyone is
exposed to the secrets that they had
long since thought dead or the secrets
they didn't think anybody else in knew
of
where that being said we're gonna go
ahead bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys
away